vamos a intentar resolver este ejercicio
dicen si es dos tercios y b es igual a
menos un cuarto cuál de las siguientes
proposiciones son ciertas y bueno quiero
ver cuál de estas proposiciones son
ciertas la primera me dice que a más b
es menor que cero vamos a ver qué me
dice esta proposición cuanto es a más b
si yo sumo dos tercios ya esto le sumó
menos un cuarto bueno pues realmente lo
que me voy a tomar es dos tercios menos
un cuarto porque recuerda que más x
menos es menos dicho de otra manera me
voy a tomar la diferencia entre dos
tercios y un cuarto y si te das cuenta
dos tercios es mucho más grande que un
cuarto si tuviéramos una herencia es
mucho mejor que se divida entre tres a
que se te invita entre cuatro y además
me voy a tomar dos terceras partes de
esas tres por lo tanto dos tercios menos
un cuarto es un número positivo y aquí
me piden que sea un número negativo por
lo tanto esta opción no es correcta no
la vamos a poner porque si la ponemos
estaremos mal así que no la selección
hemos por ahorita la siguiente dice a
por b es un número negativo y bueno eso
lo podemos ver de una manera muy rápida
porque si nosotros multiplicamos a am
que es un número positivo por b que es
un número negativo si yo multiplico un
número positivo por lo negativo obtengo
un número negativo un número menor que
cero más x menos es menos por lo tanto
ésta sí es una de mis opciones correctas
y la que sigue dice que a menos b es
menor que cero si a am que es dos
tercios le quitó un número negativo eso
me va a dar la suma de un número
positivo más un número positivo en lo
cual es un número positivo de una manera
muy rápida podemos concluir que esta no
es una opción correcta porque cuando yo
tengo dos tercios menos menos un cuarto
menos - un cuarto bueno pues eso se
convierte en dos tercios más
y esa es la suma de dos números
positivos por lo tanto esta opción
tampoco es correcta y solamente me quedo
con esta que tengo aquí a por b es un
número negativo y vamos a comprobar
respuesta del lujo estamos bien así que
hagamos el siguiente ejercicio y voy a
bajar un poco la pantalla para ponerlo
justo aquí cuáles expresiones son
equivalentes a tres medios elige todas
las opciones correctas uno entre dos
tercios eso sí es tres medios porque
aquí tengo uno entre dos tercios o dicho
otra manera el inverso multiplicativo de
dos tercios lo cual es tres medios por
lo tanto en esta estamos bien aquí tengo
menos dos por tres cuartos de una manera
muy rápida podemos ver que esta no es la
respuesta correcta porque tengo un
número negativo multiplicado por un
número positivo lo cual me da un número
negativo y este es un número positivo
por lo tanto no va por ahí después tengo
menos un cuarto menos cinco cuartos si
yo tengo un número negativo ya esto le
quitó un número positivo obtiene un
número mucho más negativo producto esta
tampoco va a ser mi opción correcta
tengo un número negativo y otro número
negativo y cuando lo sume no me va a dar
un número positivo aquí tengo 3 - 3
medios 3 es lo mismo que 6 medios 6
medios menos 3 medios es lo mismo que 3
medios que es justo lo que yo quería
aquí 3 medios es lo mismo que 3 menos
tres medios este está bien aquí tengo
uno más un medio uno más un medio bueno
pues esto es lo mismo que dos medios más
un medio lo cual son tres medios esto de
una manera muy fácil también podemos
corroborar que es tres medios y por lo
tanto es equivalente a tres medios
georges y si comprobamos la respuesta de
lujo estamos bien y bueno eso es todo
por ahora nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo